Syrian troops on the move
Edler province is the holdout the one
place President Bashar al-assad is yet
to claim but village by village it's
coming within reach occurring on towards
more villages of man's area we are still
in action stores are in a village in
spite of the Turkish support to our
enemy using foreign arms and ammunition
these russian-backed Syrian government
soldiers are fighting Turkish backed
rebels now Turkey is facing a challenge
with its observation posts in the
province surrounded and president
Richard type o Diwan has ordered his
troops to push back uh does not want to
accept humanitarian sensitivity the time
that we gave to those who perceived our
observation posts is ending
we are preparing plans to liberate our
observation posts from the surrounding
forces by the end of February one way or
another he also warned that Turkey will
attack government forces anywhere in
Syria if another Turkish soldier is
injured
16 have been killed in Syria this month
his speech came as a Russian delegation
arrived in Turkey to discuss the crisis
in Midland although President Vladimir
Putin has ruled out a summit with the
Turkish German and French leaders the
fight for control of the province has
forced nearly a million people from
their homes since early December the UN
says more than half of the people now
living in places like this are children
we left aria about 20 days ago we left
under airstrikes with only the clothes
on our backs we were left out in the
open and spent some time under trees we
went towards the city of Al Bab but we
didn't find any place to live and no one
who would let us stay on their land in
the nine years since the war began many
people have fled frontlines for the
relative safety of ed Lib now the
frontline has come to them they are
increasingly squeezed against the border
with Turkey the Syrian forces inch for
shelling residential areas o Diwan has
intervened worried about another
potential refugee crisis
we are not going to take even a little
step back in Italy we will push the
Syrian regime forces out of the area
that we designated and let people return
back to their houses but for now that's
not an option
at least 26 people including
schoolchildren were killed and more than
a hundred injured this week the way at
home its rescue group says eight schools
and kindergartens were deliberately
targeted with cluster bombs Syrian
forces have captured dozens of towns and
villages and any pushback by Turkey may
leave residents in the crossfire
Charlotte Bellis al Jazeera